ouais c'était pas très joyeux quand je
rentrais que j'étais petit je voyais des
gens qui expliquait dans les cages
d'escaliers elle me disait qu'y jouer au
docteur
google a toujours réussi un way à
transformer les choses et j'ai jamais
senti qu'elle était en galère alors que
je sais que c'est très dur d'être une
maman seule
du coup c'est pour toutes ces raisons
que ça me tenait vraiment à coeur de
réaliser son rêve le plus fou le plus
beau moment qui a changé ma vie c'est
évidemment le jour où j'ai créé ma
chaîne youtube
ça va faire bientôt dix ans ça passe
très vite à ce moment là j'étais encore
policière je crois que ça faisait trois
ans j'étais en brigade de nuit dans la
police nationale et en fait j'ai décidé
de créer cette chaîne une semaine après
mon anniversaire mais 26 ans parce que
je me suis dit mais en fait je manque de
positif dans ma vie à ce moment là
vraiment mon métier m'a mené à ne voir
que des mauvais côtés de la société
c'était très dur psychologiquement et
j'avais besoin de souffler d'apporter un
petit peu de légèreté
je faisais mes vidéos à 3 heures du
matin puisque du coup j'étais un brigade
de nuit j'étais complètement décalé une
toque ou moins 4 heures du matin j'ai
enregistré des vidéos et ça a tout
changé
petit à petit ça a pris des proportions
énormes j'ai commencé avec dix abonnés
dont ma mère et sa fille ni sur 5
millions aujourd'hui
donc forcément c'est le moment qui a le
plus marqué ma vie
[Musique]
un autre moment marquant je dirais c'est
quand j'ai sorti mon premier livre donc
il connaît un papa aujourd'hui j'ai
sorti icône de mai à l'époque donc il ya
cinq ans c'était mon premier bouquin à
l'époque c'était devenu un best-seller
il y avait eu je crois plus de 300000
vente c'était énorme personnes s'y
attendait même dans ma maison d'édition
d'ailleurs comme j'étais l'une des
premières influences aux entre
guillemets à sortir un livre à ce
moment-là et ben j'avais un très petit
budget pour sortir ce livre
donc il y avait un côté maison qui est
très présent où j'ai dû faire prendre
enfin j'ai pris plein de photos moi même
avec mon téléphone j'allais chercher les
tenues à droite à gauche et je faisais
bien attention pas découper les
étiquettes pour bien pouvoir rendre deux
jours après donc ça se trouve il ya des
gens qui ont porté des vêtements qui ont
servi à défaut se parodier de dior et
chanel sa faste il est allé là mais
quelle corde
je me demande qui s'appelle bien-être
bon je sais c'est toi photoshopée on
regarde bien
[Musique]
un moment très très marquant aussi que
j'ai partagée avec ma mère récemment
c'est le jour où j'ai pu réaliser son
rêve le plus fou
donc ma mère déjà c'est pour moi c'est
mon héroïne au quotidien vraiment j'ai
un lien très fort avec elle puisque
c'est ma seule famille en france
elle a quitté la pologne dont elle avait
27 ans pour venir s'installer en france
par amour est tombée amoureuse d'un
français malheureusement il est décédé
et elle est quand même resté en france
elle a rencontré mon père mais bon mon
père est parti quand j'avais 4 ans bref
là tout ce que je raconte est très
tragique mais j'ai voulu lui rendre
hommage parce que pour moi c'est une
femme très forte qui m'a élevé tout seul
on a vraiment eu pas mal de galères
quand j'étais plus petit je me suis pas
rendu compte parce qu'elle a tout fait
pour que la vie soit toujours recouverte
de paillettes elle a toujours sauver les
apparences mais on habitait dans des
cités pas très fun où on s'est fait
cambriolé plusieurs fois ou bah ouais
c'était pas très joyeux quand je
rentrais que j'étais petit je voyais des
gens qui expliquait dans les cages
d'escaliers elle me disait qu'y jouer au
docteur bockel a toujours réussi un way
à transformer les choses et j'ai jamais
senti qu'elle était en galère alors que
je sais que c'est très dur d'être une
maman seule
du coup c'est pour toutes ces raisons
que ça me tenait vraiment à coeur de
réaliser son rêve le plus fou et donc le
rêve de ma mère qui est un personnage
très fantasque qui adore rire se donne
en spectacle elle adore les plumes les
strass et tout ça c'était d'être meneuse
de revue du lido enfin hama pour
reprendre ses mots c'était je rêve de
descendre les marches du lido avec des
plumes dans les fesses
oh
[Musique]
je crois que c'est pour la laveuse
leader quand je les ai vus monter sur
scène j'ai juste tout lâcher je me suis
mis à vraiment à pleurer vraiment je
pleurais je rigolais jeter la loi je
pleurais en souriant c'était fou
forcément donc de réaliser son rêve
comme ça c'est un moment fort dans nos
vies à toutes les deux et ça restera
gravé à jamais